[Applause]
[Music]
and this is a show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects that I know nothing about
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
our fantastic guest this week is a
wonderful comedian Jeff Norco
welcome to trigonometry thanks a million
[Music]
he's great to have him and listen to the
question we always like talking I guess
before we get into the interview itself
is how are you where you are what's your
background what's your story no we know
quite a bit about him yes anyway so I am
a comedian I'll probably be better known
for being right of sinner conservative
our leave our working-class just scumbag
but I've been around for a while you
know I was talking about when I arrived
here was a bigger circuit comedian for a
long time since the early noughties
then I was I did like to write him for
television and yeah but lots of
different phases of my career did appear
but I did a lot of gigs for the Armed
Forces obviously I'm not talking to be
pitching for that Jim Davidson but yeah
and then you know sort of round about
the early noughties I sort of decided to
chat about the fact that I very
conservative because before he was just
odd my wife was the one that said it
really well just sit so like you know
you do the club and the club game is
brilliant you don't mean but you do end
up talking a lot about gender and stuff
like that and she and I still do to be
fair she said I said I need a new
subject need a new angle here you know
what what she said we were vying toys a
bit weird isn't it now it's a bit it's
hard to calibrate that now because that
was in the middle of the coalition which
is a slightly different era
a bit more it wasn't the Tory brand
there was much of a problem as it was
the eat and say or the Bullingdon Club
right and austerity as an idea was a
problem so I started talking about it
and people like yeah yes interesting but
I think the real change maybe happened
in 2015 when there was that surprise
Tory of majority and then again in 2016
when the levo happened so basically as
the country sort of descended in a
political chaos things have been you
know I'm pretty Christine what about you
it's interesting because you
you come from a working-class background
yes you talk in your comedy about how
your dad was just disabled right yes
yeah so you're not according to above
the waist
traditionally something of that
background you would not expect them to
be voting well expect but traditionally
I mean there's plenty of like you know
evidence that has been the case I'm
anything in the 1992 election it was
called Monday oh man you know which was
people that saw flight don't know why
you know I mean bit inspirational moved
out in London or bigger ass you know
garrage stuff like that that just wanted
to keep doing T keep doing well for
themselves I think that's one of the
things I supposed I've always had a
problem with with the Labour Party
particularly you know in recent years is
is what message that I have for
aspirational working-class focus of
which they were there are many and you
know and that's the thing about British
societies is there were these unwritten
rules about who you vote for but
actually all the evidence suggests that
things have always been different if
anything you know the toys right now are
doing very well with working-class
voters labour doing very well win city
centers with middle-class metropolitan
types so so the idea that any one party
has a sort of entitlement to your vote I
think is a soft it's a bit dated as an
idea really and have you always voted
Tory no no it started off I think always
was a Tory you know I mean looking back
looking back even when you were a
teacher even when I was at it where yeah
even you talk about like I've met in the
oratory and stand up in a staff room I
mean I I remember once I bought the
Telegraph into a staff room and they
were all right
and I didn't really I didn't even
realize what I've done wrong there but
teachers yeah they're pretty militant
you know and I I think as a kid I look
back now on some of my attitudes I think
yeah it's quite a judgy little bastard
at times you know oh because I lived on
a council we staying stuff and I'm able
live some days me and my sister would be
the only ones going to school and I and
I was a member one day in particular
like you know my family was give me
stick about it was I apparently I was
about knowing and I really gave out to
my mum for the fact that she was still
in a dressing gown at like sort of when
I came back from school I was appalled
by this fact I what
you've done anything of you though you
know you should go together just by
yourself so those evidence do it was
always there but I did vote labor the
first time you know 97 we all did right
things were going to only get better
well that was a Tory government
basically was kind of yeah in 2001 more
the same 2005 I remember at the time
there was a lot of stealth taxes a lot
more nanny state coming from labor and I
just instinctively that the council tax
everyone forgets it's council tax more
than well certainly where I was living
doubled you know and for where's this
going and if I we'd lived them in 2005
and then it was it's been Tory ever
since 2010 and do you think you'll stay
with the Tory just think well we still
going it I'm not going I don't think
I'll go any further right equally yeah
it's weird I think in a way some of the
stick I've got was radicalized me you
know as a Tory I might or V fight if I'd
have just kept these views personal at
this point I mean I never vote for a
Labour government under Corbett never
there's just not my cup of tea
that's all that's interesting why not
well because of the brand of politics
and and it's just not cities it's too
hard left for me you know yeah what I
believe in it you know intrinsically and
part of thing that makes me at all is a
like small state you know a lean benefit
system and relatively low taxation I
mean that is the opposite of what Jeremy
Corbyn you know once and also think it's
quite a regressive approach to politics
generally but but I suppose if I hadn't
spoke about my politics if Labour you
know I'm more centrist type more
sensible person got in charge and you
know they sort of move back to the
center they would have been a chance
perhaps but I've just been called a Tory
wanker so many times I sort of think
well I'm gonna live out my days and the
Lib Dems my problem with them is
obviously you know their immediate
response to the referendum is very hard
you know no you know to call yourself
Democrats and then just immediately kind
of ignore a huge Democratic mandate was
a problem at the same time as Tim Farron
was sort of revealing that you know he
didn't agree with gay people having sex
and for a Liberal Democratic really I
don't know what you are I mean I've got
some sympathy for the delivered my mum
was a liberal
my dad was a labor
and stuff so maybe there's a part of me
that was just making up you know yeah
the trio very politically motivated
people it's an interesting thing where
you touch on Corbin because and you talk
about aspirational yeah working-class
people because the thing that strikes me
about the hard left
whether that's Corbin or Errol people in
America is the sense of victimhood is
being spread so much and that ideology
this mentality that people who are
working class or people who I think
minorities whatever they're victims of
life ya need help from the government
yeah I mean for me some of that gets in
the way of what I'm able to achieve now
I you know I'm a white working-class
male who lived on a council estate for a
bit of my life the problem is from my
point of view there are opportunities
that are perhaps you know Lobby would
see me you know relatively high up that
pyramid you know some people you know
compared to would you rather be like a
posh woman or a working-class man you
know it gets it does get complicated but
they met and talked all the time you
spend worried about that you're not
actually achieving the things that you
want to achieve you know and you could
yeah I think mostly the things that I've
wanted if I've wanted them enough and
I've worked hard enough I've got now I
know people right now watching that
would be go what he's saying that as a
white man but there's no doubt that the
more time you spend chasing a goal you
know to use a phrasing left I can't be
what I can't see so you know it's better
to spend that time going for it you know
some people obviously have to protest
but that's not my style I just rather
just rather go and do it you know I mean
I mean there was no real precedent for
or certainly modern precedent for being
a that's all read comedian but I thought
rather the moaning about like why there
no Ettore comedians on I thought I'd
just see if I can write some decent
jokes you know first up and then make it
to that point where where you've put
yourself in a position to get some of
those things that you want I remember
when you first came out as a Tory it
wasn't totally dissing I mean the old
man was disappointed yeah I mean not on
the gay thing but as a Tory
I've raised you better than this son
it's cool yeah yes I mean you know that
party has been has been used before but
I suppose that's the context of the
stand-up scene isn't it how it
identifies itself but going back to the
was going to say with a moment you came
out as a Tory and I saw it on Facebook
yeah yeah and that was my initial that
was my initial impulse my initial
thought those that actually give
sabotage your career yeah by saying that
you're all right of center have what was
it like you know the first time at the
time I did it I didn't really have any
Pro for anything like that so it's more
like an anomaly you know I mean I wrote
a couple of bits on on chortle and stuff
like that people like say it's easy to
forget these and it wasn't this toxic
then perhaps you know with the passage
of time and you know certain things that
have happened is seen as more toxic now
I think perhaps the in a way coming out
as a leave though I felt more like that
really yeah the morning after the
referendum
you know I because I voted leave I
believed you know I still believed it in
the long run it's the right thing for
this country but I didn't expect them to
win yeah so when I voted I was like no I
had a very young son at this point and I
was I looked at Facebook and it's a
decent sort of focus group for the
industry see something and it was like
stupid [ __ ] racist yeah and I thought
this might I might have overdone it you
know just in terms of my own sort of you
know career and stuff like that and I
was very worried about not being out
provide for my son on this basis because
there was that a couple of weeks wasn't
there after was very one lost their
[ __ ] minds for a minute
well yeah yeah but yeah and I that was
more perhaps a time and and it's funny
how people sort of miss remember what
happened because I have also been
accused of of like cynicism as well like
so the opposite of what your Sobers I
only said it to get myself a career now
what happened was I just did have my own
back there was no real dialog in 2013
about the absence of right voices and I
did a show it was February at the
Leicester Square Leicester Comedy
Festival and it got nominated for Best
new show and then who I think it was in
the March Carol
Raphael who's head of comedy at BBC
Radio 4 said why we're all the
right-wing comedians I was like so I got
my age in the center you know an email
and try and get on her radar but I think
what happened because those two things
were quite close together everyone
fought I read that article was like I'm
gonna become a Tory because it's a
character a character has my name belief
speaking opinions do you ever find when
you're talking about brick sit in a
comedy club where everybody goes on goes
you know believers Venice I think that
that period I think things have changed
now I think that there was a period
where where a lot of comics did do that
yeah it's been a while since I've heard
that but I think that yeah people might
have misjudged the mood all right and
you've never felt like you do prog
brexit material yeah especially in
someone in London
yeah and just feel you live wherever you
go but wherever you go there were a lot
of people devoted leave I mean this is
one of the weird things about it you
know with the sheer numbers game you
know you talk about in London you know
was it 37 percent voted leave I mean if
he was in using a room of a hundred
people I am 37 of them voted leave 63 of
them voted that would feel like a lot of
people I mean in some ways at times you
won't be able to tell the difference of
you know just looking around on a pure
optics level who's in the majority here
so there's always a lot of people day
most of them don't give as much of a
[ __ ] as we do you know in the comedy
game a lot of them Oh most people of
reasonable people you know the remains
that you hear on line moment the old
true Mainers are exactly that most
people are happy to have the piss taken
out of them and the other thing is is
it's not Pro brexit material as such I
think that it's very hard to do any
comedy about something where you say I
really believe in this man and here's
some jokes about what I believe it I
mean comedy almost exclusively is comes
from what you think is [ __ ] you know so
it's aiming the satirical fire back at
the you know the remain way of thinking
and I think that I mean a simple rule I
have he's like satire is always possible
as if it's the three ages right hysteria
hypocrisy and hyperbole right now if you
think about all those things and you
look at you know some wings of the
romaine can still have sandwiches you
know hypocrisy oh so that's the big
hypocrisy so much of that playing on
both sides yeah yeah oh yeah yeah it's
totally and they were there all they've
become like each other that's what's so
odd you know I think ultra might remain
errs have become exactly and maybe
that's what you sometimes I say two
defeats I mean you have to become the
beast in order to be here but you think
you sometimes think do you realize what
what you're saying here do you realize
how [ __ ] mental
it sounds of you and I think that I
think the one bit of project fear that
has worked actually I think a lot of it
failed miserably but I think the thing
of making it seem like a no deal breaks
it is actually the cliff edge I think
that that's actually worked for most
people you know for the remain camp
the language is stuck isn't it you know
a cliff edge breaks it crashing out of
the EU there was an interesting stat
about you know they talk about the
reduction in GDP against okay because
it's not actually reduction in GDP is
against what Britain would have
otherwise had so the worst-case scenario
right was over 15 years this is more
carnage prediction so you know this was
pessimistic I mean it's like that keys
inside you it was raining you're going
and I'll just check out the window you
know yes but he said it'd be 7.7 percent
lower over 15 years now that roughly
works out about half a percent of GDP a
year now anything that's not obviously
that's a big sum of money that could
build hospitals and schools would the
average punter recognize that year in
year out I don't know you know but
they've been quite successful we can't
rate in that sort of environment in that
sense of fear
well actually the stats show that about
70% of leave voters would happily
sacrifice a chunk of their income yeah
and for example reduce immigration yes
yeah and then take him back well I mean
the top thing in the law - cough pal
Wars was sovereignty wasn't it right
self-determination in a pure sense but
that is one thing right and I had this
chat with the producer the mash report
Chris star who's a hoarder and Maya a
really good blow any you know we just we
just have said it's the one thing like
he does understand you know at least
he's honest about it I just don't get it
I just don't get it as a principle when
you think you in a way you have to
respect that there's two years on it if
people don't understand sort of total
the self-determination now they know
they never will and I think you know
they'll say things ah but we do serve
you don't because there's things that we
can't do as a country and I think that
immigration was interesting because
light is always perceived that that if
you was if he was against freedom a
movement that's because you wanted
really low immigration it's not for a
lobby was certainly myself it wasn't
that it was just it just seemed quite an
absolute ism you know freedom of
movement in perpetuity for all time you
think that you know in that any nation
state shouldn't be allowed to you know
sort of appropriate their needs based on
what was happening in their country at
that point I just thought it was strange
that that was was was decided centrally
you know and also you know when it comes
to immigration he sometimes for a long
time now in Britain people have been
able to cut the successive governments
being able to go well you know they it
makes it a negative thing doesn't it we
go well you know the EU it's better for
us freedom of movement is just one of
those things it comes with you know goes
with the territory whereas if you
actually take responsibility for the
amount of migrants come in here you
actually have to sell it to the public
in a positive way you know one of the
reasons that the Windrush scandal had
broad sort of sympathy from the public
is that was how that was sold to the
British people at the time people to
come into Britain because we need these
people to come and do our jobs whereas
for too long now it's just been seen as
one of these unfortunate byproducts of
being part of the EU well that's what I
was going to say I'm an immigrant here
right you know Francis mother who came
here as well to this country I don't
understand how they've created this
cultural meme in society that if you
want to control or reduce immigration
that's racist I don't I don't demand how
that I mean there's no doubt this some
people don't go I just want to end it
off you know like but the I think there
was that watershed moment wasn't he
remember with Gordon Brown and there was
that there was that woman who she's
spoken about a lot of different things
you know a lot of stuff that was very
primary HS and then she ended it by
saying something about immigration they
called her an awful woman I don't think
it was like you know things were
changing very fast
you know the labor government had sort
of underestimated you know the impact of
it and and I don't necessarily comes
from a place of total cynicism but but
they just had an legislators it's a way
of filing it away isn't it well if
you've got any concerns about migration
whatsoever then then you're a racist and
you know the problem is it just breed
a backlash right and and I think that
you know I think I think that for this
economy of this country to be successful
with there will be need to be you know
of course nobody but no one ever said
migration was was ending but again
that's one I suppose that's one of the
remain bits of hyperbole that that has
stuck the idea that you know people who
say oh I won't be able to go and work in
Europe now you go you know yet relative
of yours have worked in the United
States right that's not part of you know
they use so these things will be
possible admittedly they might be
slightly more than would be you know be
more forms to fill out and stuff and it
might be as guaranteed but but yeah the
absolutism has been has been quite
jarring and there's a people well
there's a March for a people to vote on
bricks it yeah yeah do you agree with
that well I don't agree in call linear
people's vote why don't I feel like you
know examine AFC Wimbledon fan it's like
I won't call that football team in
Milton Keynes you know I won't use that
because it's not is it
sure they are not the Mk II I can't say
it's a second referendum and I think
that in some ways what that betrays is
like you know people like Andrew Adonis
who just they think they understand the
public they've got you know they've got
this arrogance as perhaps born of the
play years where they perhaps where on
the public's pulse a little bit more
when I say well you know what what are
people like people like people the many
not a few you know which we call it we
call it a people's vote and then it was
immediately massively you know
patronizing but it's gaining traction at
the moment you know it's probably more
people in favor of a second referendum
now but I think that that was inevitable
as you got to the crunch point what has
been interesting about this process is
that some people seem surprised that the
negotiation is like in negotiations this
is what happens right you know
brinksmanship there and the stakes are
incredibly high so it's always going to
come to this right but um but yeah the
way that the markets get gets spooked
and still have to be a currency trader
at this point it must be the easiest job
you just sitting there just watching
like go over Hofstede stove Twitter feed
okay well he says we're in trouble power
goes down yeah there's gonna be a deal
pound goes up it's it's amazing how
these words I you know you remember
right the beginning trees may be saying
like Oh
I'm gonna provide a running commentary
on brakes it
everyone say well we should know I bet
you even some remain as good you know
where it would have actually been buried
if they do just [ __ ] off and just come
back said this is where we're at and
then we could have made the decision
then do you know what that'd be a great
sketch actually it was like a horse race
you know the remain campaign to leave
campaign and where the negotiations are
bricks it and then there's a running
commentary about the fall of the pound
in whatever else yeah yeah I really like
your idea I went a run with it yeah my
brain was going you got fuck-all I've
just got sick of the scare mongering yes
I can't be bothered with it anymore I'm
now at the point where I want to leave
because I just think that the scare
mongering you know every time you pick
up a prop you just say that you're the
entire country is gonna collapse yeah
things I believe it I suppose I think
that's the problem is if you pitched
like your fears in a reasonable way you
know like no it's stuff like data
roaming and stuff yeah I swear to God if
remain it just mentioned they a Roman in
the campaign they might have won they
just said these are the material things
that would definitely change as a result
of leave but they had to go
they have to go in for the apart and
this is one problem with like liberal
and progressive politics they bound up
in dystopian thinking they had a
pessimist you know I mean they're the
casandra's all the time and maybe that's
what happens when you're not in power
but they always want the war the world's
coming today the world you know you
often hear this thing about war with the
you know the world such a dark place
right now you know we're going to hell
in a handbasket and you know say there
were certain personalities certain
things have happening overall you know
and we often is quite parochial to just
judge that on a Western sort of metric
as well just because we feel a bit
uncertain in Britain you know they've
got a slightly you know a very
unsettling president at a moment can't
just say the world's going to hell in a
handbasket but just because you're going
through some political rocks we talked
about how things are terrible there's
never been a better time to be alive
well I mean there's that thing isn't
there like that a lot of people are left
often dismisses that global poverty is
haft in the last 20 years they cannot
accept it they're like no you
but just [ __ ] hands you know is less
let every metric of lifeless Wars less
pollution less famine but they say no no
no and it's one of those you know
there's the the information gap I can't
me what it's called but like and it
works on the right as well like so if
you ask people in Britain you know what
percentage of Britain do you think is is
Muslim you know a lot of people I think
a lot of people think it's twenty eight
percent which is not it's like about
five percent mine but equally is lot
people on the left at think you know the
global poverty is doubled in the last
twenty years and I guess I guess it
comes down to a way that you wish to see
the world almost yeah but actually his
concerns are unfounded you've done very
very well why do you think that is great
to work with very professional
no I think that look I've been around a
while as well that's the other thing you
know I've done the circus since 2001 so
when and this is the weird thing for me
in a way is like you know people on the
right would often kind of speak out
against diversity and stuff like that
and I could I suppose but I'm also like
quite a big beneficiary of it I'd like
to think that you know once the
opportunities came I was at a point
where I could take them but it'd be
fascist not to acknowledge that that if
I hadn't had my politics it would have
been hard for a man of my age to get on
those shows you know it took me a while
to work out you know how to do it as
well it's hard you know there's I think
the thing with right of scent of comedy
is that there are less subjects right
there are a lot less that lend itself
you know it's a comedy but once you land
on one its prey because it's like it's
almost a low-hanging fruit because no
one else is talking about it you know
you get first bite at a lot of those a
lot of those cherries and you also
benefit I think from from one one thing
to comedy always needs which is
misdirection you know what what was the
audience is expectation and what did you
say now if they're all thinking you're
going to say that you're Pro remain and
a labor of over you do the opposite
straight away you subvert that
expectation so you know I never been
learning and even even this toward I'm
doing at the moment and traditionalism
it started off he started off at
Edinburgh Festival last year and you
know I had to make certain adjustments
there
then took it out on tour early this year
a spring tour and then took it back to
Edinburgh for a run it's been changing a
little while right now I feel like it's
closer to what I want to be doing you
know then I ever have been in it's a mix
I suppose of hard people itical stuff
social commentary and then you know some
of its just observational comedy because
believe it or not I want to stand up
there the whole time for a whole hour
Wang Ying on about politics and I don't
think many audience members want to hear
it really and do sometimes feel that
kind of middle class or upper middle
class audiences they sort of the moment
you come out as inside right you know
and you talk about this right right
right I've said to politics a media yeah
race is bigger all the risks I think
that a less so I think that I think that
the time when that was most febrile was
maybe 2017 I suppose of when I went up
to your doober Fringe it was post grim
fail and stuff and that you know there
was a lot it was it was it was a
difficult time you know to have these
views I remember I did idiotically I did
a Facebook campaign advertising campaign
and you you guys very tech-savvy and
stuff so you take certain boxes about
you know if you do a bit of targeted or
generalized and I was like people who
are interested in stand-up comedy and
amenity you know people who are
interested in like I often use a
newspaper like you know the times or
something and I didn't take that so it
just went out generally so I paid money
for like the best parts are you for hint
yeah you want you go and it's a funny
the way that they perceive you if
they've never you know if they've never
met you they always made oh you posh boy
you know you Tory boy while you go back
to you you know you'd be landlord with
your portfolio and they basically ended
up describing a lot of things that I
wish I was actually made me annoyed
where I was thinking I wish I was as
successful they've pissed me off now
because I feel like I'm not doing well
enough but yeah they I think that I
think what's happened as well is with
you know Labour's trouble with
anti-semitism and stuff like that I
think that the idea that one side has
this kind of total monopoly on virtue I
think a lot of people get include up to
some of the more unpleasant politics on
the hard left so it's harder to just say
it's not like jedaiah versus safe
anymore
it never was but some people like to see
it that way you
I'm a good guy because you know every
five years
I took a certain boxing you took it's
just I mean it's still like I mean I
I've been think about this for years and
it still blows my mind that people think
that there's just one way to be a good
person you know one way for a government
to help people
no absolutely that's one of the thing
that blows my mind about the they've got
this belief that they are in the right
line you look at Corbin they go yes
Corbin is the Messiah and you go but
what about Venezuela what about what's
happening oh no no no it doesn't is
complete when they often say about
Venezuela they say that you know and
socialism - never been properly tried
never cut any country I'll argue to
capitalism's never been fully tried you
know I mean that you you look at any you
know perhaps that sort Peregrine's of
capitalist virtues which is Britain in
the u.s. still you know there's still
were state institutions right there's
still a lot of you know her interference
in the market I'm not saying I disagree
with all of it but you know that hasn't
been tried at either end and I think
that if you look at both experiments
that have happened yeah one of them
tends to end up with higher inflation
let's put it that way
yeah and coming back to comedy you were
talking about how the atmosphere a fee
brought in 2017 my sense of it now is
with people like yourself coming through
we talked about Finn Taylor who's I
don't know whether he's right center or
not but he's someone who does satire
yeah a contrarian so if yeah exactly so
I start to see people like you coming
through do you think that people in
channel 4 and the BBC and the people who
control comedy on television are
starting to wake up to the fact that
half the country doesn't actually want
to be constantly bombarded with these
yeah same same same message I think
definitely the BBC you know it's
interesting for me because you know I
the summit something even people to
follow me seem to think I'm being like
excluded I'm like what I've done live at
the Apollo
anyway my support and question time so
things take time as well I think that
maybe there was a period where things
would let slide and it because there was
always balance in political comedy once
upon a time wasn't it you know I grew up
like probably yourself like spitting
image you know there was a day always
went for Kinnick so that was how my
political comedy psyche was formed I
think something happened somewhere along
the line where that just ceased to exist
I don't know I don't know why that was
but something changed
and I think that what happened with the
brexit vote was it was like Avengers
infinity water everyone was fighting
each other you know it was all kicking
off and you had you know you had
metropolitan stories who were who was
Slayton you know kind of rule Tories
that had voted leave you had liberal
labor voters slaying sort of socialist
voted leave and I think it's a real
setting reset in politics and the idea
that you could still I think most people
accepted that comedians were probably
labour votes for whatever reason they
just did I think breaks it was different
and I think they took the industry a
while to kind of come around to that but
trust me there's they're you know
they're they're conscious of this fact
and they wanna you know and I have
meetings all the time with people that
don't agree with my views and stuff but
you know the producer of the mashup or
what would be one example that if
anything pushes me you know to be more
honest and stuff and and you know there
was a clip recently about breaking up
with a remain Ramona yeah did like half
a million views and you know the other
thing is numbers talk and [ __ ] walks
and I think that would have raised some
eyebrows really as you know when you
were talking about sort of being pro
brexit being Tory and yes you get I
sometimes feel especially when it comes
from the left they think that they're
actually persuading people yeah yeah you
know oh you know what if I excite enough
horrible things about somebody they're
they're gonna go actually here's my
epiphany you were right all along I will
join your side yeah I think it's just a
way of like patting yourself on the back
isn't it yeah I don't know what what the
the emphasis was and I think you know
it's like I think it's like being a hot
a tough guy right
you know guys who can really fight they
really need to tell you that they're
tough it's a saying yes I've seen the
tattoos but they are flowers so just see
that right-hander coming in and weird
little face stroke but I think it's the
same as if you're a good human being you
know like if you really knew felt
confident that you're a good human being
would you need to keep going around
saying that you know I think I'm a
fantastic you know but I what I kind of
what I think what I do in in comedy
sometimes is everything you do in comedy
is a slight amplification of a part
for you and and what I got asked when I
did Mashable particularly the first
episode because are you making it up or
do you really think these things do you
think well I might like if you have a
conceit right or or a hyperbolic fault
you might not think it all the time but
you certainly had to for once so not in
terms of my overall politics but just
like I had this idea the Mashable
basically which was people over the age
of 80 shouldn't get NHS treatment
because it's all just and you're not
still even as I say it I'm like you know
it is a sledgehammer crack a nut but
like I just don't know I'm not saying I
don't know the gist except they would
just be but maybe they'd be a bit more
careful
I don't know I'm sort of a pulling
myself as I say but but this was the
point I did have the thick before right
so I thought that's funny it's funny
that I thought that right and so
sometimes with my comedy is like you
give you give the inner bastard a little
bit of a runaround right you know it's
not it's not a fake part of you it might
not be the total part of you but what
happens when you get critiqued by people
especially if they're not disposed to
your comedy they'll they'll they'll
point out that fact we don't really
think that so you know you're a fake or
something you think well on the left put
commits I mean if you look like Stuart
Lee and Frankie boy who don't get me
wrong within a brilliant I mean
brilliant political comics but they so
much of it is hyperbole right but if you
already agree with that point of view so
if somebody's talking about you know
post bricks it will all be enriched like
yeah if I can you know really think so
we're gonna be in rats right but that's
just the way of making a point yes
sometimes yeah sometimes and the funny
thing about that routine was my wife's
granddaddy who still about he was I and
then we got chatting and that was where
the lawyer you know I think there was a
line of said Bay you know what he's
sitting around for another golden year
in the day room watching cash in the egg
when actually we want your cash that's
in the egg and yeah that's the that's
the idea but but yeah mostly people like
mostly people get it I do think that
there is this thing that I have had
where as if people just don't like the
idea of me you know it's like because
I'm working class as well because of the
way I communicate some people see
to be aggressive I just Sears I grew up
in South London yeah but you didn't get
fixed at school yeah I did get to school
often boy often what girls that I went
to school in them I went to school in
wonderful for a while called South
fields you would you yeah I don't know
what it's like now problem with schools
these days if you don't mention over 20
years someone go against a really good
school now so all your war stories are
[ __ ] off a bit and you're like yeah
and then I'll tell you now the story
about getting beat up by girls you know
it's really respected you know faith
school now and but but yeah so I'm just
back in their memories of because you
know you've raised that way by your
parents never hear it go but it's really
difficult when the girls literally
kicking the share of you and I'm not too
bad like slow I'm talk about might
actually landing shots you're miss and
at the point where she landed one of
them I thought that was a good puzzle he
was really proper like landed square on
the jaw yeah it's good you would get
being up I go called Lorena's well it's
a good old-fashioned yeah start from the
rain from one's work yeah well I was
gonna take you back to more serious
about voices like yours now being heard
Lucas yeah traction do you think we're
we're kind of past the point where we
were so polarized that we couldn't
listen to the other side and now voices
like you was a kind of gonna start to
lead to a bit of a rebalancing I think
that I think that for us they still I
would imagine the vast majority of
people in this country because obviously
most of them won't have heard of me if
you say that all week immediate know
what I mean that'd still be you know you
still have seen not like the Florentine
might have an Edinburgh when they're
selling its people that's still the
reaction you know so I've and also at
the time that I'm getting on some of
these shows the overall audience for a
lot of mainstream BBC comedies you know
I mean compared to the lovely
Apollinaire gets what just over a
million you know a lot of comedy shows
get the good ones get around that mark
when they were clocking in at four six
million once upon a time so so you know
the idea that you can completely change
people's opinions with one you know
stuff sitting around online at she
surprised me that that actually just
getting your clips up there you know on
my youtube channel
but you know just leaving it there
letting that that stuff grow as well and
I think that for the average punter in
the public you know this balance is a
part of life it's only within our world
that the idea of somebody having rights
interviews or being a leaf owning comedy
was weird and that's what I found out
she often leave photos doing the cutting
edge two nights later at the Comedy
Store and I've seen the majority of that
panel were sort of left-leaning remain
voters and we've gotten well with us you
know we had a good conversation
backstage and they were like right we're
gonna go name we're gonna have me you
and stuff so they did but what happened
was the audience would I would quite a
lot of us finally like oh so
straightaway and also then he worked for
me as he look like I was getting bullied
yeah yeah and yeah so you it was an
early sort of like reminder of the sheer
scale of of the numbers involved in and
even if there was a room of 70 people
that you know 70 percent voted remain
maybe all of those people have got
relatives that voted leave as well and
they'll probably know that you know in
the most part they're not evil as well
so so I think that's what's happened
we're still in a phase of just getting
to grips with this absolute reset you
know that's happened politically in
British public life oh one of the great
things about your voice is that like a
lot of people in comedy just don't seem
to acknowledge it your voice exists and
especially when you know that all the
echo chambers of Facebook I thought we
were going to storm it with yeah well
the first one was 2015 actually when
they happen people like I can't believe
that the powerful charismatic leadership
figure ed Miliband isn't Prime Minister
I was full of Miliband it was him that
was you know right from when he got the
job I in any culture any civilized
society leadership is something you
expect you know whether it's irrational
or not and he just wasn't the guy I mean
like in so many in so many elections
being prime ministerial is a big deal
part of reason that's the reason I
didn't get a majority last year was
because she didn't seem prime
ministerial so like a lot of things I
wasn't shocked that the toys won a
majority I think the echo chamber thing
I think the people are conscious of it
now more although I've actually started
to like the echo tone
I think I've started to create one of my
own I thought you know it took me a
while but now when you've got by me oh
this is nice it is very nice like with
the show that we do we have a lot yeah
yeah it's lovely
that's very nice see why it's so
comforting yeah comforting but actually
I was thinking that Miliband is exactly
the kind of guy you see on a playground
beaten up by a girl
yeah yes he's quite tall Doeg quite
rangy I'm not by the way no no I'm not a
strategy yes I'm sorry could and this is
the shy Tory phenomenon you go how many
people in here voted I come up whether
it was vote or e of only yeah both Tory
and three thousand people you've got
like three you know I've gotta be honest
I suppose for me that's great for me
cause yes it makes it look you know I
did say them beforehand if loads people
cheer can you edit that out
no in that room um yeah there what there
wasn't like a big and that was you know
last year and that was wild things work
were so tense and it's not it's week
somebody said to me about the other day
about like a kind of like a balls out
maneuver I didn't I don't know why I
didn't really think of it at the time as
being like that because I've just been
saying that at the Edinburgh Fringe and
stuff but when I look back on it in a
room that size and the gig you know it's
live at the Apollo biggest gig close
feet closest thing any comet gets to
plane in if I can't find it right yeah I
think I did the equivalent of like a
halftime just bringing on the tricky
little winger you know what it's still
you know what a going game was still
close but the the audience I think most
of it right and this is true of all
comedy the audience are looking for a
sense of who you are is this person I'm
a bad person you know a nasty person and
what's a tone of this comedy I don't
want to get into this whole punching up
or punching down thing because I think
we've got to locked into the idea that
again like it's a binary thing I think
it's far more complicated than that and
to because I've read a lot punch you
know sore sideways 360 yeah I think it's
possible to play with those boundaries
but I think if they get the sense of you
that you're not an ass
some of them would have Falls and also
do you know what the funny thing about
that live at the Apollo appearance and
in some ways like an indication of the
age that we live in the biggest pushback
I got off that off online what so I
mentioned a joke I did a joke about
concentration camps as well yeah I think
I talked about being a Tory and stuff
I'm did I did a routine really innocuous
routine about my wife taking shoes on
holiday and there was a I've got these
responses quite standard was about you
can't say that about women and sometimes
I'm not saying that about women I'm
saying I'm about my wife you know I've
become quite cautious one thing I did
listen to from feminists was like yeah
you extrapolate about all women
sometimes you lose me because I think
well that's not me so I thought all
right if I talk about my experience no
no one can ever tell me that I'm wrong
about my own relationship as long as I
know I'm being honest yes no you're
wrong about this you're such a [ __ ] and
then the other thing is I figure right
now you're sliding my missus because
you're going like you're saying this is
a horror concept of what a woman is I'm
going that's what this is how my
marriage is it might just be you know
and you know oh yeah a controversial
concept that broadly speaking there are
quite a lot of women that like shoes
this is the problem with like the modern
online communities they make it easy for
me it seemed controversial they make it
way too easy
because I'm not controversial I don't
know you know I've got like you know my
views are more or less if you look at
the Overton Window like I'm almost bang
in the middle of it right and and yet I
can't have like some sort of edge lords
for saying and this what I say to them
sometimes like because because well as I
mock the week the other week so I did a
few jokes about remainders and they all
made the edit right so when it when it
when it went out of C people there was
certain kind of person that was a bit
surprised a bit triggered bit shocked
and and then so like I just have a chat
with somebody and they were saying yeah
when I read the twist often went on it
thinking what did he say and of course
what I said wasn't that you know sort of
adversarial it's just a couple of jugs
about the idea of a second referendum
but what happens is people so if like a
tweet about me you know like gets a lot
of likes then people will see that
they're nothing [ __ ] who is this guy
yeah this guy's out there he's mental
and then I've the only thing that annoys
me about is the idea that they come to
my come to my shows and they expected me
to talk about you know sort of
drop-kicking a toddler or something in
it and the truth of the matter is
is the you know I see myself as you know
it's reasonably reasonably familiar
opinions you know but ultimately you
know you can say we can pro-fascist
apparently because of this podcast you
can see something that Tim's you see the
way I just checked you out there when
one this is our words you said
professors are we're like what Bates I'm
just interested what basis you
professors know yeah yeah but in the
second world war memorabilia when you
say something like for instance I don't
agree with Corbin I would never vote for
Corbin I'm not hard and because I
disagree and say I would never vote for
the son but for something like Jeremy
Corbyn all of a sudden that means you're
not part of my camera you are the enemy
therefore you are a fascist I don't
think it's about that at all I think the
reason that we get called right-wing
podcast or a fascist or Nazi apologist
is not because of what you said because
of what I say it's because we talk to
people from both sides yes yes that's
why so if we have someone who's a little
bit controversial you talk to people
both sides of the Nazi debate we talk to
people on the right with your superior
on the left and I think it's that it's
the fact that we talk about free speech
a lot yeah yeah I think that's the
number one well yeah that is a problem
and I think you know we do talk about
the tone of the debate on on the hard
left is is some of these these terms
like fascists racists and stuff he's the
they you know they simply think that
they're like you know in Karate Kid the
crane kick you know yeah they seem to
think that that's always going to be the
conversation ender and once upon a time
possibly it was problem is is that you
keep rolling it out every single day on
Twitter you know every single day online
for people to pay in Leon it's such
serious words it's such an awful thing
to be like like a genuine my biological
racist is probably the worst sort of
view that you could hold so
once people see that applauds people to
patent me on then then the word has
already lost its power and that's what I
think that they've running up against
now and that's and in a way and this is
a problem for the left is that you know
some legitimate cool I mean it is very
much the boy who cried wolf
ya know isn't it some legitimate
criticisms of people and now people are
able to sort of shrug them off because
they're now looking in in a litany of
things where people have you know again
it's this thing hyperbole people have
tried to get get an idea across the line
with with emotion and guilt trips rather
than with reason and it's a good example
of what you're talking about because
every time Francis calls Tommy Robinson
far right so we get a bunch of people
going he's not far right it's just a you
know a normal guy and you go well I'm
any piece not far right what right and I
think the reason people now think that
way
yeah because that label of racist it's
been so debased that you don't really
knows what a racist is anymore yes I
mean yeah I think it's well like this
one the problems is in public life is
remember people get accused of being
racist
no one ever owned it either you know and
I'm not this is not a proven of racism
but everybody but people say that things
that are patently [ __ ] racist right
you know all been caught saying stuff
that's racist you know Mel Gibson I mean
those phone calls if you've never I mean
they're just mind-blowing my face
somebody just come out and just said you
know yeah I'm yeah yeah you know they
never say this arm and only that they
always go to the opposite of saying I'm
the least racist person least you know
me you don't use those words male if
you're not a little bit you know I'm
just saying it's a spectrum and you know
you're closer and then you are dying so
I think on both sides it's been fudged
right you get the people to call people
with racist impossibly aren't racist and
in people a clearly racist like you say
going no not me you asked anyone in the
tiny community of my wife right and and
they'll tell ya I'm a lovely bloke we
know a person that possibly depends on
me being in work weirdly they will
support you know my character
[Music]
know where we are politically and we've
all been so far to the left and I'll be
honest with you
the Tories where they are do you think
the Tories are gonna win the next
election and do you think more
importantly do you think they're missing
a trick with voters like me who are
drifting around in the center guy I've
got no political well they are trying to
HR trying to pitch here I mean like
Theresa made that one recently where she
said you know labour bows if you're not
happy with Corbin and stuff I think that
before anything is known about bricks
it's gonna be hard to make a real land
grab for those folks because people are
it just feels like we're treading water
towards something I think post that and
I think if if breaks it isn't as bad as
people think it's gonna be and I don't
think I don't think it's even possible
they could be this sort of like I keep
thinking is don't you know that you're
in a cartoon when the wind blows you
know like they were one we had about a
nuclear holocaust yeah the problem
domain comes if you said that day if it
comes in anything above this sort of
like you know Mad Max territory you
could claim it as a success Goble you
said we'd be in rats and actually we're
in pigeons and something breaks it wins
right yeah but it but once we get beyond
that point I think that there is and and
I do think that the Tories have a few
tricks that they can play I think the
next generation of politicians that
they've got or actually will surprise
people you know they're probably they do
need to look at the diversity in their
own ranks because ultimately young
voters value that but luckily for them
they've got talented politician so james
cleverly you know a lot of people have
Ruth Davidson
they've got Sajid Javid you know Sean
Bailey am who's the the London mayoral
candidate so I think that the tough
thing for labour at that point is once
you get a more diverse Tory from bench
some of the old cliches aren't going to
stick you know maybe for I you know
proof Davidson is the leader of the
Tories well working-class lesbian yeah
what are you gonna say well you you're a
part of the Bullingdon I mean nothing so
I think that yeah going forward I think
that if the Tories can can get some sort
of breaks it dealer isn't quite as
catastrophic as people think I think
that it's easier for them because I
don't think I don't see how labor can
get rid of Corbin
next two or three years and while he's
in power I mean you know I've been doing
this tour and stuff and you got to
Northwest there's a lot of Labor those
socialist that just don't like the man
so he is toxic figure you know to some
people but it's very hard for them to
get rid of it so I think there's always
have got a chance to pivot sooner than
Labor have we talked about the left a
lot and we criticize the far left and
you've done and we do from severe mental
health well make both our comedy careers
are pretty much over on the basis of
this show yeah that's fine I was gonna
ask about the right though because the
far left has gone mental but the far
right is gaining traction it certainly
feels like yeah I mean we took mentioned
Tommy Robinson the guy's got a million
subscribers on YouTube he's all over the
everywhere
he's did you keeper talking about
bringing him into the party so that does
seem to be that that movement yeah that
is picking up I know this so I might
have someone like you who's center-right
mmm would be quite concerned of course
of course in many ways like this is one
of my big concerns about a second
referendum and about about the need for
there to be a meaningful brexit is
because if there's not the the narrative
for the far right he becomes so easy
doesn't it I mean like in terms of a
pitch that disaffected you say he's
simply this like they didn't listen to
you
we will that's all they have to say you
know you you you told them what you
wanted right you know there was a vote
you know and and it hasn't been action
you know especially I mean like you know
is one thing of fudge and bricks it but
some people I mean this is just fine of
amazing people I just think we should
just stop it just it's like I just like
it like a really harassed mother you
know just yeah
brick city mother a headache just but it
like it's this bad thing like getting
passed over for a promotion that they
can just make go away you can't you have
to deal with this hot potato
and if you don't that is the problem and
you look at it's scary i watch that
watch that film yesterday by paul
greengrass a 22nd of July about Anders
Breivik and you think this is going back
to 2011 and this is broadly a factual
factually based film and about
that rise you know and it would have
only carried on and and the need to
engage with those concerns at the very
least because there's a lot you know
there's a lot of people that feel that
way and and if you literally ignore a
democratic mandate I don't know what
happens next genuinely and I think know
what people could end up with you know
people on the center left and left
thinking that you know and people like
myself I'm thinking that you keep there
we think all you get were the good old
days of you know at least you keep we're
embarrassed about their racism and they
see at least oh pretend that they didn't
say stuff you know me there would be you
know you know I mean people that was a
difference between like the IRA and Al
Qaeda and then people say oh you are a
with the gentleman bombers right yeah it
would have been the races that were
phone in a warning yeah where his you
might end up with something you know and
people who express a lot of people you
know they they're worried by something
like Tommy Robertson but yeah II think
you know in the future it lawns me the
idea that there could be people actually
maybe not MPs but there could be people
are sitting on councils and stuff like
you know I mean it happen and it and the
idea as well like that sort of brexit
started racism in this country I think
that it's so it's so ignorant because if
you look at like but you know back into
the northeast where didn't we have a BMP
counselor we did in Burnley yeah you
know in the early part of this decade
the EDL were formed and there were there
were marches so and this was before
referendum was even on the table so yeah
it may have bought some and it's not
doubt that you know there is a branch of
breaks of thinking that comes from that
but the idea that this is where it began
I think is is there's another way of
ignoring a really tricky issue and do
you think though just to finish up with
embrace it but do you think when you
have people like Katie Hopkins coming
out and paying bro bricks it what yeah
actually did was taint and diminish what
the movement was about yeah yeah well I
mean one of the tricky things for
everybody about bricks it did you end up
standing on a really long platform
waiting for a train with like you know
in any pack train there's gonna be some
pricks on it right yeah and yeah so so
but that doesn't mean like you said you
still believe in the destination and
it's true for you know and I know for a
fact there's some people that were
nodding along to david cameron during
the the you know the the referendum
campaign some people who've despised
tony blair for years but you know he's a
leading life it's made us it's forced us
all win some really quite uncomfortable
alliances but that's because it's a
binary idea it was always going to do
that and yeah there are you know but
they were there are plenty of
personalities involved in the room I
mean Andrew Adonis I don't want to keep
it's been [ __ ] I cannot believe he's
a real person you know I know if you saw
it did this video right he said like you
know we gotta get out of Metropolitan
bubble you know and I want to get some
answers and stuff so he goes this video
right and he flinches beast about to
leave I swear man he goes mm-hmm and
then he's not hanging around he's really
young people in a playground and they
like going
I think breaks is gonna ruin my life
he's like yeah so it's doing a half
minute video he what he claims he's
gonna do on it on his on his kind of
like journey outside you know outside
the metropolitan ally doesn't for about
four seconds and he I think he's a
divisive figure I mean yeah Katie
Hopkins his divisive in in a very
obvious way I think something got Angela
Donna see it's not not to that degree
but certainly you know some of the
patronizing way that he talks about
leave voters is he doesn't really you
know maybe he doesn't realize help
triggering that could be and I do get
sometimes when I hear remainders
especially in you know innocent
metropolitan London and the way they
talk about believe Oh God oh no you just
are not working class people no country
in their heads you know it has brought
that issue and this is one of the
reasons I always thought right from the
beginning I might be proved wrong
because of the way that negotiates have
been handled by the toys but I always
thought it would proved more of a
problem for the Labour Party because he
would kind of launch this boil of what
the party really is you know what the
majority of their own Peas are and how
they feel about the world and you know
that that other part of the Labour Party
and bring it out into the open and
certainly in the first six months after
it seemed to be weirdly they were cast
in the role of left-wing patricians
weren't they really yes so say no no you
you know we shouldn't you we should have
had the vote you should have been
allowed if I leave it to us you know we
will sort of take care of stuff you
return us to power you know we'll take
care of things and I think that a lot of
people have evolved their thinking since
a lot of people on on the left you know
this and don't get me wrong it's plenty
of old fashioned you know I mean that
was one of the interesting things about
the vote was you know people like Dennis
Skinner
you know Tony Bain and stuff people just
conveniently forgot that there was
plenty of very solid left-wing reasons
for voting leave I'm calling himself is
so weird isn't it I mean it's such a
simple thing but to stop and think that
you've got a prime minister who's a
remain of it's trying to make an
opposition leader who is a lever there's
sort of be imported it's so there in the
weird way they're like the only two
people in the world understand one
another
yeah like over like they do you know
like old toy action maybe you know just
get [ __ ] hammered together like in
secret it's very strange once you
actually stop and reflect on what's
happening but you know what I do think
as well I do think that a deal will
happen in the end and I think that what
will happen then is is the press will
continually report on any evidence that
you know things are going wrong all
right I think most of British people
will go like out really like to talk
about something else for a while you
know I'd really like to give it a year
or two and just just see how it goes
because we have done we've done a lot of
this and you know and like a lot of
leave voters it's not like I think i
soften my stance a little bit in the way
you know I was very cool you know
because when you get represented in a
certain way you know the natural thing
is to I've become that thing or ought to
be to be resentful but I sort of think
like you know it was 50 to 40 yeah it
was a close vote you know and you know
ultimately you you got to move forward
at some point and I don't think that
it's part of reason you know in terms of
the comedy that I do it would be I could
probably get a bigger audience right if
I was like yeah you remaini act pricks
and you know stuff like that and it's
just not I don't think it's constructive
do you not mean and I think that in a
way it's a harder thing to do to get
somebody to reluctantly who started off
maybe thinking that you're a stupid
racist prick
to just end up thinking you're a stupid
prick
well on that positive note time for us
to wrap up so the last question we
always ask Jeff is what's the one thing
that no one's talking about that we
should be talking about I think the the
sexual ization the representation of men
and the way that women talk about men's
bodies and looks and stuff is obviously
there was paint this really didn't
expect that no no no no no no I think
that what's been happening it's no doubt
like the objectification of women is
still greater yeah you know and the men
is still less but if you look at the
direction of travel right and I've
noticed this a lot in social circles of
stuff that women are quite bold in
talking about what they like about the
made of men looking you know it's sort
of like they're experimenting with a
certain Liberty you know like Poldark
and stuff and yeah I even heard on radio
5 live the film review program and they
were they were talking about him recap
all these were two female sort of
hosting guests they were like well you
know Henry Cavill says that brightens up
the place and I was thinking that is
literally the kind of stuff that was
said in the 70s by men brightens up the
place yeah and I don't mind because you
know I've grown up in an age where there
probably was like a massive imbalance
but I do think that you know for my son
who's 2 and a half now
you know he'll grow up in an age where
it would have gone full circle where
he'll be doing a bit away and stuff to
start you know work and then woman would
just smack him on the ass and him go you
know actually I don't feel comfortable
with that level of contact and I think
that so if you just look at the
direction of travel I mean I've done a
couple of them I've done a couple of
corporate gigs recently this is where I
was you know you get guidelines right
and you know just just be careful around
issues of me2 and feminism and stuff
like that and then you're on stage
posing for photos you got a woman
grabbing your ass and then you mention
it afterwards everyone laughs you know
that's fine
I look I don't feel under threat in that
situation but I think it's not an issue
perhaps for me it's probably issue 15 20
years down the line where you know it
won't be you know seen as quite such a
playful thing we'd be able to do social
media update 20 years down the line you
what told you say yes and on that no
it's been a lovely interview Jeff we saw
anything that you'd like to plug but you
got your tall yeah so Twitter you know
you come and say hello
what's your handle is Jeff nor got Jeff
aubergine or cotton o RC o TT most think
that's where the biggest sort of
following this and so YouTube channel
dose we've got a few more subscribers
there need to do more on that and then
the main thing I'll see is I'm on tour
at the moment and right through till the
last day of the winner bit is December
the seven for Leicester Square fear all
around the country and then there's one
straight day in January in Exeter but
it's been brilliant doing the tour as
well like I think one thing that people
sometimes think about coming to my shows
it's going to be this kind of echo
chamber of meathead like like levers but
so far I've done five days of this leg
and it's been a majority of Romania has
been a slim majority sometimes the slim
majorities all you need yeah if you
haven't seen Jeff before he's absolutely
fantastic comedian check him out we'll
put a clip for your YouTube channel
we'll make sure that we connect that
will be all over Twitter and everything
else Jeff and I are both actually
performing comedy unleashed in London on
November 13th so come along to that if
you're free and as always follow us on
social media at trigger pod subscribe to
this YouTube channel if you enjoyed it
and we'll see you next week with another
brilliant episode absolutely guys and
also if you're on iTunes leave us a nice
review that'd be amazing
see you next week bye bye
[Music]
you
[Music]